[Music]
let's go to
richmond virginia where austin joins us
austin how can we help anthony ken it's
a pleasure to talk to you guys can hear
okay yes sir hey
so um i'll give you a little bit of
background um
i am 100 debt free um
my fiance she's still in school she has
um she has a little bit of debt she has
about
2 000 on credit cards seven thousand on
student loans
but you know she's she's graduating in
december
and she's you know she has school paid
for her mother works for university so
she gets free tuition so
um we are pretty much both on the same
page
with as far as debt i know i am i
do not like debt yeah no debt no no like
you gotta say
she is almost on the same page she's a
little more tolerant than i am
but um i guess the big question is we
are you know making
we're planning our wedding right now and
uh
we have a strict i have we have a strict
ten thousand dollar budget
and um she is starting to
get a little you know iffy about the
budget the closer we get at first she
was like
oh man yeah yeah yeah but now she's
you know we're starting to make some
real decisions she's going out wedding
dress shopping and you know we have
a certain amount budgeted for her
wedding dress and she's i guess she's
kind of scared
and she's like oh no i don't know what
wedding dress i'm gonna get so
i guess the real question is and it's
starting to cause a little bit of
problem in our relationship so
i guess the question i'll boil it down
to is is compromising
on the budget for the wedding okay for
the happiness of the relationship
[Laughter]
let me ask you this question awesome do
you have any room to compromise on the
budget
um maybe a little bit i'm trying to
no seriously do you have any room to
where you can
go up and give like an extra couple of
thousand dollars
comfortably where it's not going to hurt
you all's future you're not robbing from
your emergency fund like is
it's can you maneuver some things around
uh for the sake of this wedding
that's a simple yes or no question yeah
yes i can
how much how much more is that honestly
um probably about maybe i could make a
thousand
dollars on there or so but i don't know
you know where it stops if i compromise
some address
do i have to compromise on something
else and i don't know where to give into
it
i don't i don't think it can correct me
if i'm wrong i don't think
you tell her what to do i think you tell
her hey babe we set out we agreed on a
ten thousand dollar budget i hear you i
want this day to be
absolutely amazing for you um
so i i went back to the budget i can
squeeze out another thousand i don't
know what you can squeeze out but the
key thing here is we're not going to
rack up any debt
and we may not have everything we have
but you can choose how you want to spend
11 000
and let her choose what she's going to
compromise on
but i think as a man you are showing her
that i'm trying to make this
the best way possible but also i want
you to see that i'm trying to be a good
steward with the financial resources
right and then you put you put it back
on her to like all right i'm gonna go
buy a 3 000
address but then i may bend over here um
and go from there what is specifically
you guys have talked about this is there
a specific number in her mind
or a specific item and will the thousand
dollars i love how eeo walked you
through this that was beautiful
is that gonna solve it it doesn't sound
like it does to me like it solves it
because you're like well what happens
when she comes back for a thousand more
that's the way you basically reply to
that so that leads me to believe
there's been a couple of conversations
and i want to know what specifically is
going on here
how much more are we talking about where
does she want more money
i don't know i think it's i think it we
we have pretty much everything set we
have the venue
and the caterer i think she's kind of
just afraid of the
um of the of the unknown she's afraid
that she'll try on
a you know three four thousand dollar
dress and fall in love with it
um and then i'll be able to get it
because
i guess we're restricted to the budget
okay so
okay this is great that's what i wanted
to know okay
uh if you gave a thousand dollars more
because that's your limit would that get
her to where she would be able to afford
the three thousand dollar dress
um maybe but she hasn't gone wedding
dress shopping yet that's my old point
she needs to go shopping first and start
looking at stuff
and getting a range of stuff let's let
me tell you something
ao and i both love clothes okay
no shame on our game we like a nice suit
both of us we would come from the church
world
ao we like custom suits we've we've done
that before nice here's the deal
i go look at stuff and look at materials
and look and shop
and then i start pricing and then when i
start pricing i start going oh
i can get this level of a suit for this
i could get this level for this
if i don't want to spin this what do i
do i start changing the material that i
might
she needs to go dress shop this
conversation doesn't go any further
until she goes dress shopping and she
starts looking at what she
likes and what she would feel beautiful
in and let's put some real pricing out
there otherwise this conversation
doesn't happen anymore well let's let's
let's add to this ken okay because uh
if you tell a woman to go dress shopping
and then let's talk about the budget
she look all the ladies out there
looking at me like i know where
anthony's going
she going to find a 10 000 address no
and come back no she's not gonna do it
yes she will no
come on now so this this this is my
suggestion i think y'all need to come up
with
hey bae you can spend 3 dollars on your
dress
now go find a dress that you like within
that believe it
i'm assuming austin and i appreciate
that ao
but for everybody who thinks i'm tone
deaf she's already said to you i'm
scared i'm gonna try out a 3000
or four thousand dollar drink that's not
gonna happen she knows what it costs
but she needs to go out there and start
trying some stuff on is my point yeah
but you can go on amazon and get it
dressed for five hundred dollars
but she's not going to that's not gonna
happen
you know what i'm saying i mean i mean
look
i'm just saying you can find a dress in
in any budget kit
i'm just saying i think for her was what
i feel as if
this younger generation hears from their
peers oh you you gonna spend about five
six thousand dollars on the dress
of your life and you're only gonna wear
it one day why spend five grand on the
dress you're only gonna wear it one day
um that's my thing it's all relative
it really is all this is relative but
that's probably why i'm still single
because i ain't
mm-hmm you're all carrying on with
confidence about wedding dresses i'm
over here going man i've been there done
that
okay i've already been through all this
i like how you walked him up to the
point of going look
here we are this is our first major
money discussion we're about ready to
get married
right and money is the biggest money in
kids
and i throw faith in there those are
your big tension points in marriage
right that's good and if he's saying i
can only go a thousand more i thought
that was great that you walked him up to
that and i would say to that young
man you can make more money go ahead and
kick in a thousand dollars but they also
need to actually go dress shopping
and she might think three or four
thousand is her her lane
she might see something for two i don't
know i haven't checked wedding dress
prices i i've been married 23 years i
don't have a clue
okay but what i'm saying is is that
they've got to get to a level of
true understanding here i need to
understand you
you need to understand me let's figure
out what really really matters here i
want you to feel beautiful i want you to
look beautiful
i understand it's a big day i'm excited
about it but
we got to go see what's out there and
not just assume that well i'm going to
need more money because i've started
looking into it that's what i'm
this is a moment for this young couple
they got to really figure this out
yeah because you don't want to be you
know last thing you want is her
in the back room of the church crying
crying
because she didn't get the dress she
wants ah man i want to say something
right there but i can't that's probably
a good idea
i don't even know where you're going but
it's probably a really good idea